[Music]
after I got hurt it was painful to sit
on the sidelines and watch other people
play sports and participate and not be
involved when I started this interest in
photography it was an opportunity to get
back into sports again my name is Lauren
whittington and I'm a photographer when
I was 21 years old I wanted to be a
baseball player I was playing one
evening and I had a great double that
was a lousy triple and I slid into third
base came in contact with the other
players knee and it pinched my spinal
cord the result of that was paralysis
I'm a c-56 quadriplegic I've been in the
wheelchair for the past 30 years it
wasn't until almost 20 years after my
injury that I picked up her camera
adapting the camera is kind of an
extension of learning how to deal with a
disability I cannot use my right fingers
what I figured out is that I could use
an external shutter control with my
mouth and take the photograph the type
of photography that I do is about people
who are involved in adaptive sport and I
felt my best photographs were of people
with disabilities because they saw in me
somebody that they could open up to when
I take photos of athletes I want to show
them as somebody who works hard who
compete part and who wants to win it
really shows more about the athletes
than the disability when I first started
shooting adaptive sports I immediately
set my goal to taking photographs of the
Paralympic I got the phone call from the
United States Olympic Committee that
they were interested in me going to Rio
de Janeiro in 2006
game there was some of the most amazing
athletes there and it worked out same as
what I've always had to deal with if you
just got to try it probably the first
day it's not going to work so well but
after that you just start getting better
and better at everything you do you can
have a regular normal body guy with a
shirt off trying to inspire people you
can add me a guy with no legs at one arm
my name is Nick Stanton says oh I had
pan heart syndrome and Han heart
syndrome is a rare genetic disorder
which either leaves the baby was
undeveloped limbs or underdog organs
when my case it was just my limbs that
were you know affected middle school was
like my rock bottom I was always asking
you know why was I born like there has
to settle sauce wrestling started me on
you know the answer to why I had a
standing ovation to my law and I just
didn't understand because I'm very
competitive person I'm like you're not
supposed to like here on someone else's
after the matches that have parents
coming through like hey like my kid
never did a sport and he saw you today
and now he's signed up for all the
sports you know because he sees that if
you're doing it like there's no excuse
for em not to it was like that's why I'm
here and I wanted to break into the
fitness industry because I was inspired
by these fitness guys that you know sit
around with the six-pack next to a nice
car but getting into it it's much more
than that it's how you can move people
and show them that like living healthy
lifestyle and not as hard as you think
it is especially if I can do it my life
revolves around you know eating and
training and posting I look at being fit
i look at motivating inspiring of this
duty I got a message from a UK mom she
had twins and one of the twins leg had
to be amputated she said that they
watched the videos together and he goes
like me Mom he's like me Mom I didn't
have that as a kid I didn't have someone
to look up to that kids can you know oh
I don't know how to do this let me look
at next page that that's why I do
[Music]
or your shoulder blades back together
there you go writing and doing it
excited if the deal is really keeping me
alive okay three more correctly but if I
were to start work it out as a deal out
of house you did by now okay my name is
waiting for craig washington and under a
professional bodybuilder I know you can
seek my hand moving oh my god knows with
her apology i Ju 11-month you know we
got off with scoliosis at the age of 12
when I first went to doctor they had
told me that I was not going to live two
feet Enid oh wait and I have been
friends here at the gym I'm his personal
trainer yes and he approached me with a
very serious tone and he told me that
she wants to do a bodybuilding show you
know one of my goals would be a
bodybuilder the other one would be a
perfectly rational with the resin was
too dangerous in the beginning he didn't
have the control to get on a machine and
just work the body parts that we were
intending to work his hands and his feet
need to be stabilized you in yes alright
so I got very creative and I built up
you know apparatuses that would fit him
in order for him to secure himself and
actually pull with the muscles that i
was wanting him to do above above them
up you can said it it telling me what
you your Genelia twin to give you so
let's tell it what to do again okay okay
the way I approach everything everything
I'm saying I have to focus a lot of
horror and a lot more a wood fire plug
that were the old to make it work right
for me that's
Wow it hasn't ended up and has improved
a lot the basic happiness that comes
from feeling strong and feeling able
instead of disabled is a big deal my
buddy has done illustrator I hope he
would tell me that old taller Oh every
state is feel well but it's called teen
Wade accomplished his pro status as a
bodybuilder it's the most unbelievable
experience this is something no one ever
thought could happen and it happened we
made it happen it's an amazing I'll
bliss to hell a coach latina or friend
latina I enjoyed being a pro bodybuilder
it's my lifestyle now
[Music]
travesti daivam a no mercy oscar de
volver never samoa andorra la valle de
Galeana or even now Odie 19 gather one
dog scandal and the really nourishment
and then how much Malachi did one of it
before i roasted Oliver you Nina is the
oldest known woman happy st. clairee pie
yet an ancient south indian martial art
the art of Flowery expected to use the
force their hand six and heavy sword and
shield at Norland an olefin is leaning
on Marlon another body in love it oh
mama monetary yes I'm Methodist about a
month ago survival see I have another
idea i cud mud en la casa de na na na na
ma ma ma ma okay Kylie
nobody tells harry chatwyn overriding
within man freedom I untidy demise okay
I sorry well morales ID but Khalid
aboard the module another one not
allowed in idlebury cut cassinelli party
cards are holding available yoga in
order for download here are over the
rotatable appear under or over several
another another scuffle over there were
under scalar booty under africanum day
you get a polar quadrotor wonder bunch
of all number hey when I am raised never
increase my left leg a modest and
everything in working like a video that
other one no and I 8200 so you can only
log Adams yeah I was always big my story
was that I was fat and I was sort of
doomed to be fat and unhappy and not
live the life that I wanted to live so
being able to break down that story it's
been a lifelong process for me and
that's what I really am aiming to share
with other people is that that story
doesn't have to be true
[Music]
I'm Dana fall Betty and I am you okay yo
gets for everyone why do people need to
be skinny to do yoga this is it's just
it doesn't even make sense for me it's
the only thing that you need to practice
yoga is the willingness to try welcome
so even bigger breath on this inhale so
belly rises up towards the sky Rock the
hips from side to side anything that
feels good I travel all over the world
teaching body-positive workshops so I
don't necessarily teach in a way that is
about modifying or making the practice
easier for anybody based on age or size
or anything like that it's more about
teaching in a way that makes everyone
feel really included and really
comfortable and lift the left arm up I
don't care what it looks like I don't
care what any of you look like just do
it and just feel amazing
[Music]
from like Age 10 or so on I was always
big four years ago for going to the gym
and just being really active in the
pursuit to get smaller and I lost almost
a hundred pounds I got to my new body
and everything was exactly the same I
wasn't happier and I didn't feel any
better and so I was at this point where
I felt really just kind of lost and
confused about what I needed and so I
went to no gun
before I practice I didn't realize how
capable my body was because I just felt
like it was fat and like I was lazy and
I believed everything about my body that
sort of society sees when they see a fat
bird
I love my body it which is crazy because
I really spent my whole life hating it I
mean looking in the mirror to feeling so
disgusting and I'm proud of it now and
I'm proud to take care of it
[Music]